oh Bob at one seed in Goodfellas when
they're having a breakfast they got the
body in the trunk of the car that and
Bob was curious when Jimmy Burke liked
ketchup and so he wanted ketchup on this
Italian breakfast oh okay get Jimmy to
ketchup but Jim Bob was curious you know
how did he take ketchup out did Jimmy do
that did he do that did he do that how
did he do it and I got a hold of Henry
and he says hi to Edward Jimmy used
Ketchum how did he do it he says oh he
did it that way and so in the movie Bob
does it that way and I watched it I said
oh I just gave it an authenticity to
detail Bob found his character in Little
Things by the watch the jacket the tie
the haircut he feels the character he
knows who the character is down to
whether he's got manicured fingernails
or not